what are two or three things that a
director cannot afford to get wrong
because if they do the movie is ruined
wow that's a big question two or three
things they can't get wrong cannot
afford okay out there's one thing I
think Aaron that I think is really
important that and I include myself in
this that we all fall into a trap that
we all fall into and what I call it is
the trap of assumption okay
the trap of assumption is let's say I
have a script and I really like it and
I'm moved by it okay
my assumption will be that other people
will be moved by it somebody else will
could read it or see this film or
whatever and be moved in it I could be
wrong
I'll even take a scene have a scene
between a husband and a wife and there's
an argument going on and husband is
really angry at the light for some
reason and it's to me it's clear he's
angry at her because of her attitude her
impatience now I'm done something very
small and my assumption is that the best
of anybody else watching it would get
that it may not be true the problem is
this when we look at in the script on
ask in a script I'm just going to take
one thing I can read that same gown and
I can read it as I say it's just two
pages I can read that scene and I go I
got it I can see what's happening I can
feel all the energy between the two
characters I can feel the conflict I can
feel the resolution I can feel all the
obstacles everything that they're going
I get it quite honestly those two pages
none of what I felt is there I can tell
you that right now none of it none of
the conflict and even the characters is
there all it is is words typed on a page
no different than a novel no then it's
just words on a page what happens which
we all have to recognize is when you
look at a script you project into that
material
what you believe is happening you
actually anybody who reads the scripts
can suddenly hear the characters they
can see the characters where is that
coming from it's not coming from the
page it's not there there's no pictures
of the characters there there's no
action there nothing there's no emotion
there there's no performance there
nothing so what we do with every human
being does is we project into those
pages what we believe is happening in
other words those pages are triggering
me those pages that I'm reading trigger
mark marks history marks life experience
marks expectation everything it's coming
from me so I project into it now Karen
you will do the same thing but why
should I assume that your projection is
the same as mine that's the danger of
assumption I assume that you'll get it
the same way I do not true maybe close I
don't know so the trap is the trap of
assumption I assume that you're going to
respond that way I could see a scene ago
that's so moving then you're going what
I don't get it not like my reaction was
it was moving here so it wasn't my
assumption is you should get it so
thinking that just because it works for
me it should work for everybody else yet
ironically the flip side of that is also
true I the director have to make the
movie for me I can't make it for anybody
else so I have to allow a certain level
of assumption to going on I'm assuming
because I made a movie that I really
like this moving to me I have to assume
that it's going to be moving to enough
people that the lots of people are going
to like it
so we're trapped in the world of
assumption but trapped in that we have
to do it but be aware that it could be a
problem okay so how is someone aware of
their own assumptions so let's suppose
you think these two pages of very moving
dialogue between two characters is just
heart-wrenching because you see the
world that way or that scene but
how are you bouncing that off someone
else or I don't know yeah yeah I think
so and I think I have an answer for it
let's stay with this one scene because
sometimes just looking at one figures as
a movie is you don't make a whole movie
as you know you make these all these
little change and put together it
becomes a movie
so let's and you have to be very focused
very myopic about that scene so let's
say we have a scene between a husband
and wife and getting back to you how do
I deal with my assumptions I'll tell you
one of the biggest assumptions I the
director can have any director will have
every director will have I read to say I
know how it should play I is the
director know how this scenes should
play should now I'm the director so I
get to decide I get to decide how I want
the actress to play the mother and how I
want the actor to play the father now
this is what a lot of actors to do and I
could a lot of directors will do I'm
sorry that's what a lot of directors
will do and I can tell you right now
because working with a lot of directors
I'll say to a director who says this is
how it should go I said how do you know
well that's that's clearly the way it
should play I said how do you know I'll
talk to them about projection so there's
that assumption now we're going to mix
with that something else which makes it
even more difficult you have the two
actors now there's two actors read the
scene they're making assumptions the
actress Leo I know how to play this the
activist si I know how to play him now
we have three people who have different
points of view on how it should play and
I can tell you right now the director me
and those two actors right we're all
wrong we are all wrong we are right
about our assumptions we are right about
our opinion but we are wrong our opinion
actually does not matter all three of us
the only opinion that matters is the
opinion of the characters
the character the husband life they know
and we're trying to tell them how they
should behave
the actors are trying to tell them how
to behave by controlling them I'm trying
to tell the actors how to control the
characters how to portray the characters
if I can get to the character get to the
truth of the character my assumption may
be blown right out of the water and the
actress may be - or may not I don't know
but my job as the director is to serve
the characters that's getting back to
what your question was before serve the
story not my version of the story their
version of the story I want to get to
the truth of who they are I want to get
to the truth of these characters that
the writer created that the writer is
also making assumptions about and the
writer may even tell me oh it should go
this one I said well I don't know if you
know either let's get to the character
and this gets down to the interrogation
process which is talking to the
character I want to know from the
character what they want what they think
that they feel now one thing that's very
important which may have been in the DVD
I gave you probably is but one thing
that's very important this is a concept
is if so to me is so clear and so
obvious but nobody talks about it as
soon as I bring it up in Wallonia the
characters in your movie the characters
in this scene these two people this
husband and wife whoever they might be
are not in a movie
they're not there to people who are in
their life there in a moment in their
life which happens to be the scene
trying to achieve whatever they're
trying to achieve they're just two
people they're not in a movie they don't
they do not have a script and we are
trying to present them as authentically
as we can to a viewer well in order to
do that we need to honor them not my
point of view necessarily not the
actor's point of view necessarily but
them let's let's present them as
authentically as we can I have learned
so much about characters and story by
talking to the characters by in a way
and I mean it seriously dismissing a
little bit what the writer says what the
actors say and even what I think I go
and I talk to the characters and I am
sometimes so educated and enlightened
about who these people are so they're
the ones I'm here to serve they're the
ones that the writer is here to serve
that the ad were all there in service of
characters so let's talk to them now the
interrogation process which we can talk
about later is a way to get to them and
get us the writer the director from the
actors out of the way many times getting
to the truth of the story the actors the
writers MA and the director are the
biggest obstacle we are in the way of
what we are trying to achieve
you